exclusion je retiens surtout sur gta 5
pc enfin j'ai installé plein notamment
un petit renner qui va nous mettre bien
on peut par exemple avoir des gardes du
corps voilà c'est mon crew c'est mes
amis je les aime et du coup on peut
animer une vraie colonie quoi allez les
enfants on y va ici on est tous
absolument génial ouais j'ai acheté le
jeu pour ça moi vraiment jadot aux 10
dont elle m'a roulé sur les claquettes
les enfants je vous mettiez il s'est
passé quoi le voc est têtu en forme mais
oui on est tous attristés par cette
terrible nouvelle il est le coupable
j'aurai sa peau c'est lui voilà c'est
bon je me suis mangé carlos tué le petit
dernier de la famille je suis désolé
mais je dois tu abandonné add your eyes
non j'ai maté [ __ ] ça va aller tout va
bien se passer un maillot rose est
passée un peu comme superman et
attention um c'est la guerre qui
commence à losone tôt soit là du coup
y'a rien encore mais ça va pas tarder il
arrive c'est le débarquement [ __ ]
c'est scandaleux ça regardez moi tous
ces [ __ ] d'avion là qui veulent me
bombarder aide toi je te mets à goutte
est directe ces parades
il ya des mois ça c'est scandaleux oh là
là mais c'est invasion d'avions indiens
c'est juste incroyable
allez je me dire je sais bien que la
télé dans une voiture j'étais pas loin
au but et les sages penser aux usa qui
va tailler vassy et laissez-moi direct
on paie bien là tout je te rattrape
raymond gars savent ce que tend au
talk-show quatre attrapés
méfie toi aïe aïe le spawn qui les
[ __ ] là on dirait superbike qui
découvre ses pouvoirs je suis dotée de
capacités hors du commun
je mens bon pas vraiment finalement
attention le voit sa note au passage ce
que je fais ça rate je dirais jamais les
pour nous au tableau au plat ouais on
l'a fait
faites moi je voulais dire dans le
cerveau noah a par contre je chute de
manière très violent ok bon alors déjà
où sont mes gardes du corps dans un
premier temps je ne me balade jamais son
garde du corps voilà ils sont là c'est
la ferme de los santos ici et je nantis
on m'agresse que ça fait attendez vous
qu'on aille voir voilà attends je suis
bien au bar demandent 200 à 1000 avions
pas connu une chute de cinq mètres non
scandaleux j'avais [ __ ] simon qui sont
venus me voir dans l'idée hôpital comme
ça elle veillait sur moi j'ai envie de
voir s'il ya quelqu'un qui me tape ce
que si elle m'aide ou pas en fait je
mets un petit coup est ce que bon il se
relève pas [ __ ] merde oui j'essaie dû
prendre sa voiture il va il va
m'embrouiller c'est sûr oh là là ya pas
de mec viril mais choqué vouloir se
battre au plat non mais pourquoi
personne mais j'ai trop de force et quoi
pas dangereux et bien sûr oui parce que
dans bon oui vraiment mouillé vas-y à
lait les vaches et des mois est ce sa
faute est d'avoir regardé mais sans
faute quoi le regard papa elles veulent
juste bien des parts mais bande de
lâches
vous êtes sûr de vouloir malgré c'est
comme ça c'est là que je vous montre un
nouveau mode véhicule canon ça consiste
à tirer des voitures et mon pc ça va ça
va le pc il a subi deux bateaux à roger
a battu auch et vous aurez tout venant
faire croire en face au oui c'est beau
ça regarde moi ce petit plat est normal
et stakes non mais le respect à tu veux
ma glace était sur mon appel au pouvoir
de l'internet
allez-y les chiens défendent et moi vous
êtes fidèles voit un peu comme j'aime
bon ouais c'est pas ce que je dis ou
vous embêter les steaks de moi qui a osé
faire ça mais mais mais mais mais des
morts c'est toi c'est toi mec chose en
plus de ça tu touche pas aux chats plus
tard est ce qu'un jour je pourrais vivre
sans policiers
c'est pas ça en regardez comme c'est
beau désavoue les policiers profiter de
ce doux spectacle c'est beau on va aller
à la maison michael voilà avec s'étaient
retournés à la baisse en fin mai mais un
mot ici alors il ya des mini jeux qu'est
ce que c'est que ça par exemple je me
faire attaquer par des chiens au pierre
meyer du corps attention à nickel
parfait mais il ya un chien quoi
mais quelle armée mais c'est mettre des
clowns aussi assez grave ça mais rata il
a peur des clowns de ma carrière mais je
peux mettre des aliens aussi assez ok
c'est un alien et se bat comme carlos 9
93 fois attention le cloud va te tuer
attention attention à toi oh là là toi
je me suis fait arrêter quoi ici à mes
vaches au moins qu'ils viennent me voir
à la prison oh oui oh dire eh bien elle
même trop elles sont mignonnes en époux
soit [ __ ] à thomas planque
je vous aime mes enfants on est une
belle famille tous les quatre attendez
je vous aime mes enfants non il a tué
mon frère mais vous agissez pas vous en
foutez et compris toi le coq y compris
toi le croque adieu au talent pamiers
adieu aux gels ou bien encore me saouler
la êtes vous prêts à voir le cascadeur
le plus talentueux de sa génération
c'est parti mon gars je suis à poil
métiers des phoques
ah non j'ai un short voilà on va
atterrir en douceur dans un lac cette
fois je vois ce qui fait pistolets
paralysants jamais essayé au nom mais
oui non mais là c'est pas réaliste en
baisse et pistolets qui tu attends je te
pousse dans le lac puis va dans la co op
latuquois l'eau du bois alors [ __ ]
c'est vraiment horrible
il est oublié non je veux le faire sur
des animaux carrément portage de faire
parler des copains tient des coyotes
c'était copains je te fait apparaître
des copains les marre d'être la victime
de ayo et nous odieux alors je mange ce
qu'on aille dans un bas déjà ça va nous
appartenir dans une seconde
[Musique]
ce mignon regardez comme il est mignon
alors j'ai coincé le véhicule comme une
merde
quant au rhône sur la piste ait salut je
viens au club et c'est pas toi qui
n'empêchera t'es vraiment le plus beau
c'est pour toi que je viens c'est pas
pour le club tu sais je t'aime fort je
te dis tu es si beau pardon mais je
t'aime non mais je t'aime à ma manière
si tout est art est un peu un allez on
rentre avec mes potos inquiète sont tous
beaux gosses et venez les gars en face à
ce club de strip-tease prend une toute
autre tournure en vidéo alors les
poteaux vous vous amusez bien c'est
l'éclaté site laissant tout bloquer le
club mais elle peut plus bouger regarder
on est enfermé tous les deux maintenant
mais je suis bloqué bordel allez bon
sens tout cela c'est bon tu veux voir un
super spectacle regarde papa papa au
shit bat avec ses sérieuses à rio
attendant mais c'est un bordel ou en
fait c'est l'apocalypse dans l'eau
santos bordel de merde
et moi je suis atteint de cette vidéo
sur gt5 avec tous ces modes [ __ ]
qu'est ce qu'il est bon ce mode avec
tous les avions gdaxi vous appuyez si
ces cas n'hésitez pas aimer les
sangliers
je sais pas on s'en prend à une vidéo tu
peux y aura d'autres modes qui sont
sortis parce que là on a fait le tour de
mon intéressant mais puis je vous dis à
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo mason
avoir regardé chat au monde pis
[Musique]
mais